Hello, how are you, Hector Mejía greets you with
his informative brief today is Thursday,
May 20 starting today the
mets and food for life stores
will not force the use of face masks for
people who have the vaccine this applies
to people who enter  the store
and for fully vaccinated employees
however these
supermarket chains are asking those who
are not to please continue to
wear their masks
the metro police need to help
solve a murder case
east of downtown las vegas' this
happened  a little before 11
pm last night on 14th and stuart streets
outside a catholic church
detectives indicated that neighbors
heard a shot and found
a lifeless victim on the street no one
witnessed the shooting have a
description of the subject yes  you have
information do not hesitate to call the
authorities separately there is new information about
the murder case of this palace the
for  Clark County officials indicated that
there is not enough evidence to
determine the cause of death of the
young woman, they argued that her body
was exposed to different factors for
almost two weeks, meanwhile, the
palace family does not rest until
justice is done for one of the suspects.
in this case it is still fugitive now
we turn to the weather forecast
we will have a hot day in the
80s today thursday however there will be
40 mph winds in the
morning and part of the afternoon we have a
drop in temperatures around
the 70s starting tomorrow  Friday and they
will last until Saturday have a nice
newspaper your electro mejía and this was your
brief neo jeans news in
Spanish
[Music]